Crusades. So, what about the Crusades? I
mean, the people leave Europe and they
go to the Middle East to take back
Jerusalem.
What Was that not an act of aggression?
No, that was actually part of just war
theory because based on what I just was
saying, they knew the Crusaders and the
church that that land, the Holy Land,
was originally Christian.
And moreover, they knew of what was
happening, all the attacks and the
violence. And in the years and decades
before the First Crusade, this is when I
was referring to the Turks. I mentioned
the Ottomans, but before the Ottomans,
you had the Seljuk Turks.
And they're the ones who precipitated
the First Crusade.
Because what they were doing is really
horrific. According to contemporary
eyewitness sources, they were massacring
tens of thousands of Christians in Asia
Minor, primarily Armenians, Georgians,
Greeks in Western Anatolia. And at the
same time, there was always pilgrims
from Europe going to the Holy Land ever
since Constantine the Great built the
Holy Sepulchre in Jerusalem and and all
these other sites. They had always been
going there even during, you know, the
height of these after the Islamic
conquest and
depending on, you know, who was the
ruler at the time, all you had to do is
pay money and maybe you can visit, but
sometimes you'd get attacked. During
this time, right before the Crusade, the
the Turks were just running havoc and
the stuff they were doing, you would
people would travel thousands of miles
and when they get to the gates, they
demand money from them, take it and then
they hit them and whip them and kick
them out. There's a very notable story
where a German
pilgrimage went there. This happened in
1064 and it you know, eyewitnesses say
they killed everyone and they and there
was this beautiful nun and they gang
raped her to death, okay? And then
there's other stories about when they
would go into churches and completely
defile them and
you know,
disembowel the priests and decapitate
them, you know, pull the entrails of the
young boys and whip them around. And
that's so if you really study the text
and you look at why Pope Urban called
for the first Crusade in 1095, that's
why it was because because of what was
happening. So in that context it was
seen as just war. And this is holy land.
This is this was Christian before the
Muslims conquered it in 637, Jerusalem.
And now they're doing what they're doing
to the holy sites and to pilgrims and to
Christians in general. And so the would
often cite another verse that they would
cite
is where Jesus says the two greatest
commandments are to love God and to love
your fellow man. And that was understood
loving God in that sense was you know, a
lot of modern Christians don't
understand this anymore, but holy land
sacred sites were important. Okay, so
God was being dishonored in this
construct by what the Muslims were
doing. So loving God was to go on
pilgrimage and liberate the holy land.
But loving your fellow man, your
neighbor as that verse says, was also in
the same context cuz you're going to
help and liberate the the indigenous
Christians and the pilgrims who were
being abused. So yeah, nobody nobody had
any problem with it in that context. The
problem is
it's not presented in that context. And
so I'll just get I'll leave you with a
quick quote
from an old from a professor John
Esposito, maybe you've heard of him from
Georgetown University. He was very
popular back in the day when I went to
Georgetown University. And you know, he
was the editor of the Oxford
Encyclopedia of Islam, the later version
of the water doc version. He has a line
in one of his books that says and I've
I've paraphrased it so much that I've
actually verbatim now. I've He says five
centuries of peaceful coexistence
elapsed between Christians and Muslims
until an imperial imperial papal power
play, it's an alliteration,
led to a series of so-called holy wars
that have left the you know, legacy of
enduring mistrust and grievances for
Muslims. So, despite what I just told
you, which is Muslims conquered
violently three quarters of the
Christian world, okay, and all the
atrocities in 1009, okay, this is again
a few decades before the first crusade,
one caliph of the team at caliph in
Egypt, according to Muslim sources
Al-Maqrizi destroyed 30,000 churches and
synagogues as well in greater Syria in
the Middle East basically and Egypt.
Which on the one hand underscores how
Christian that region was as I was
saying and on the other hand underscores
of the persecution that was going on.
So, all of that you know,
that's what was happening and this
professor is telling us that that before
the first crusade it was all peace,
okay, and when you see it that way and
that's how it's presented, of course the
Crusaders look like the bad guys because
they're colonialists, they're racist,
they're xenophobes, they're
Islamophobes, you know, they're going to
a land that they have no business in and
they're engaging in violence, but if you
really understand the context, it's it's
the exact opposite. Bring back
Bring back
In the righteous